let's try carl from
california carl from california you were
on the air
hello yup what's up how are you
uh i was wondering uh how is the
um copied numbers planning on going down
is that like a specific date
event that um
[Music]
you know the code numbers are supposed
to like
calm down are they going down i don't
really know too much about this
they are going down yes so cases are
down about 85 percent from the peak and
declining
deaths are down about 82 from the peak
and declining
yeah okay oh that's good um i was just
wondering um
is donald trump planning on uh going to
a re-election and
what do you think he do you think he can
make it i don't think we will know until
we see the 2022 results and what i mean
by that carl
is donald trump wants to be the king
maker in 2022. he wants to decide
who are the good republicans and who are
the bad republicans and who gets
reelected and
because of the decision made about did
you see what happened with liz cheney
earlier this week liz cheney
the republican congresswoman was
stripped of her leadership role by
republicans i don't know if you heard
about that
yeah um sorry here's one more thing
uh oh i haven't even answered the
question yet carl but we can move on it
sounds like you have a big agenda to get
to
yeah sorry this is something that i was
actually uh
came here for oh okay so you had a video
and it said biden hits uh 63
approval right 63 of approval yes
and one of my friends said that was like
um not correct like it was
done the polls were like specifically
biased
for the democratic party how were they
buying
um one second okay
take your time carl please yeah
sorry oof
are you are you lifting weights
uh yeah you are okay all right all right
carl thank you for the call we'll see
you
um i mean it's just it's off the rails
guys that we'll publish that because
it's funny but that don't don't be carl
don't be carl one of our sponsors
purevpn
is giving you 47 off a one-year plan
which comes out to less than
six bucks a month purevpn makes you
anonymous online
and you can trust them they're the only
vpn with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity
is not being logged purevpn keeps you
safe from hackers prevents you from
being spied on by your isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week for just 99 cents
and you'll get 47
off a one-year plan which is less than
six bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman